oh so you must have been like one of the
earliest
people on youtube then i would i would
consider myself like in the second wave
of youtube there's a lot of like og
youtubers from like 2007 yeah that's
like when it first started i was 2009.
okay it's been wow it's been a journey
for this
[Music]
what's up mkbhd here so quick background
uh before you go down to the comments
section and say hey why didn't you also
talk about this or why didn't you grill
him on this policy or this election
stuff and you know there's a ton to talk
about i'm sure if we had a two-hour
podcast episode we would have gotten to
a lot more stuff but he's a busy guy
and so we originally had scheduled we
slotted 15 minutes to talk tech
so my my thought was if we only had 15
minutes to talk tech with mark
zuckerberg what would we talk about
anyway this is that conversation enjoy
all right mark what's up man what's good
how how are you thanks for having me on
yeah i'm good uh so for the talking tech
series i think uh we always start by
an introduction i don't know if you need
an introduction to this audience but i
think people know you as the co-founder
of facebook the face of facebook but
i'll let you introduce yourself what's
your what's your role every day and what
is that like for you yeah well i i
i guess i started the company and i've
been running it for the last 16 years
and you know i i think you know my job
is pretty varied you know i never really
know when i wake up in the morning what
um you know what is going to be thrown
at me that day but but overall it's a
it's a really
interesting mix of of intellectual
problems and um you know i just i'm
grateful to get the chance to to build
stuff that so many people around the
world love and use every day it varies
from you know the set of apps that you
might have on your phone to some more
far-reaching
advanced technologies like the work that
we're doing in virtual and augmented
reality which um is is personally one of
the things that makes me the most
excited
we have these announcements um coming
out at facebook connect um about some of
the new work that we're doing that's
really interesting actually do you do
you split your time on the regular
between facebook instagram
uh oculus whatsapp or is it sort of
every day has a little bit of everything
yeah
i definitely split my time a bit more
because there are just so many pieces at
this point that if i were trying to tune
into everything every day then it would
just be too much context switching so as
a matter of fact what i try to do is
like have a theme for a week and you
know maybe usually i can't get away with
just one theme but
and i'll try to do two or three things
in a week and have most of my time be
focused on on kind of nailing that and
doing a good job at that then of course
different things come up i'm talking to
people throughout the day but you know
we have really good people running each
of the apps you know it works well as a
team and and that that allows me to
focus on on you know some of the stuff
that i think is the most important and
and whatever is coming up that that um
that i need to deal with so i think one
of the most uh interesting parts of the
talking tech series when i get to speak
to people is everyone has a unique
perspective on tech in some way and
obviously you being
at the head of a very important company
like oculus that's what i'm most
interested in because at the head of it
you kind of have to have some sort of a
vision for what you think the future of
it is
which is i guess hard for me to wrap my
head around but
can you talk a little bit about oculus
now like the oculus quest 2 by the time
this comes out will be the newest latest
and greatest but what what does that
future roadmap
for a company like oculus look like yeah
so if you look at the kind of broad
history of technology
we get these new major technology
platforms every 15 years or so and each
one delivers a more immersive experience
and allows us to communicate with the
people and and
businesses and things that we care about
around the world with with just higher
fidelity and
when i look at what we have today you
know on our phones um you know phones
are pretty amazing right it's you have
this like incredibly powerful computer
in your pocket but it's not the end of
the line right there's all these things
that i think are not
that good about it right it pulls you
away from um from the world around you
um it's it's
anything but immersive right it's a
small screen so the question that i've
been asking is you know what's the next
wave of technology and what's the next
platform going to be and what's that
going to deliver for how we all connect
and for me
the essence of virtual and augmented
reality is
that you need to have a technology that
delivers this feeling of presence right
the sense that you're actually right
there with another person and all the
different sensations um that come with
that normally right not just seeing
someone on a screen but you know having
the spatial audio so it it sounds like
if someone's standing over there the
audio is coming from there um having it
so that you can you can kind of you know
if you're interacting with them and you
have an object you can pass them the
object right and it's kind of real time
and there's no latency you know our eyes
um refresh every five or ten
milliseconds so you know having it's
that you can have this whole 3d world
and what other people are doing render
um in in real time faster than that so
it just feels real
um i think that's different right in
every other type of technology platform
that we've had you know game consoles on
tvs computers
you kind of you get some pretty amazing
software
but you're basically trying to convince
your brain the whole time
that you're in a different context than
you actually are when you're really just
kind of sitting on your couch or your
desk
vr and ar are the first platform where
it really just convinces your system
that you're in a different place you
almost have to have to try to
convince yourself to snap out of the
reality sometimes and realize hey this
actually isn't real i'm in a different
physical place but that's pretty
powerful
so there's a long line of technology
that we need to develop to fully deliver
that sense of presence but i think
that's really what we're in the business
of doing with the oculus virtual reality
product lines and with the augmented
reality glasses that we'll
that we're working on over the coming
years um is just how do we deliver that
sense of presence and connection for
people yeah you know i think that i like
that train of thinking my
a question i get asked a lot is like
i do video now on youtube and my goal is
always to make the highest quality video
possible so like i can put a product in
front of you and it looks as realistic
as possible almost like you're holding
yourself but what's the next version of
that maybe the next version of tech
reviews
10 years into the future after its
youtube videos
and my natural answer has been
i think vr makes the most sense if i
could literally kind of like put you in
my shoes
then you'll feel like you're in the car
that i'm driving or holding the phone
that i'm holding is that a dumb answer
have i been giving a good answer this
whole time i mean i i certainly agree
with that but you know i mean our
company is probably investing the most
in virtual and augmented reality of
anyone else in the world so um yeah i
mean i would hope that ten years from
now or five years from now you know
people will have
a you know relatively sleek pair of
goggles that they can put on
and basically transport into your studio
where you are and instead of just
holding up the phone in front of you
like you just did um they could grab it
that you can hand it to them and they
can they can play with it and and kind
of
experience that themselves
or maybe the lighter weight version of
that would be augmented reality which
you know i think
you're still gonna you have to go into a
some kind of different mode
to want to put on sunglasses or goggles
and have that fully immersive virtual
experience for virtual reality but i
think augmented reality once that hits
and you have a normal pair of glasses
that um you know good-looking kind of
normal glasses not not anything that's
that's super thick or anything like that
and that can last all day long but can
project holograms into the world um then
you'll be able to do a version of your
show where your um you know your
hologram can just show up on my couch
right here um and you can hand me the
phone and i can and i can kind of take
the phone as a hologram and play with it
like that um you know i mean one one
kind of trippy thing that i think about
that's further out
is once we have really good mature
ar glasses
we won't even necessarily need other
kinds of screens anymore right things
like tvs um
you know it's tablets all these things
could just be digital holograms um it
could be apps that you know some kid
halfway across the world and some other
place makes and you'll be able to get
completely um kind of new designs for
things like like tvs and and kind of
different kinds of shapes that are not
like the regular thing that that you
know samsung can make in their factory
and i think that there's just going to
be a crazy amount of um
creativity that gets unlocked and a lot
of innovation when when a lot of stuff
that physically today has to be produced
in a factory which obviously most people
don't have access to doing that um can
just get turned into an app that can be
a hologram that you can give to someone
i think that that's going to be wild so
i'm really excited about and that's why
that's why we're we're just so focused
on this and we have you know thousands
of people working on this at facebook
because i just do think that this is
gonna be the next major computing
platform even if it takes you know
several years to get there right and so
you so do you see like a world maybe
where where screens or displays are sort
of a past where you literally can
project with ar if the tech is good
enough you can just hold like a
a rock or whatever like a a very simple
inexpensive object and with your ar turn
it into
a a screen if that makes sense you know
i mean
the real thing will always have somewhat
amount of more fidelity than you'll be
able to get with
um
with augmented i mean
like haptics are one area where you know
you want to feel something you pick up a
rock or an object and it kind of has
more weight that's kind of hard to model
but i do think we're going to get
other senses
through augmented and virtual reality
that may not be possible in the physical
world so let's say for example okay i'm
like i'm kind of feeling around on my
desk and my hand is getting close to a
water bottle where today you don't feel
the water bottle until you touch it but
it's possible in ar or vr that we can
provide some kind of
sense so as you start getting close to
an object you start feeling some kind of
resistance or or kind of or or some
sense that you're you're near something
um which of course does have some other
animals um you know navigate the world
through um sonar and different things
like that getting a sense of different
so i think it's going to be pretty
wild i think a lot of new things are
going to be possible um
it's not that it's going to replace all
physical things of course not a lot of
things you still need to be physical but
you know a lot of different types of
media books games different things that
people have tvs
it's not actually clear that in the
future those all need to be physical
objects anymore i think a lot of them um
you know if you're sitting next to me
your hologram is here with me you know
and maybe maybe um another friend is
kind of uh sitting next to you on the
couch hologrammed in from somewhere else
and we want to play a game of cards and
i can just kind of snap and here's a
virtual deck of cards and i can like
hand them out right it's like i just
think that that's going to be pretty
wild um yeah so i think that that's
going to be really powerful but there's
obviously a lot more technology that we
need to develop before we can get there
gotcha yeah see this is why it was a
good idea to talk to you because i'm not
i'm not thinking this far into the
future and now i'm like okay you got to
address all of your senses
you know your sense of sight your sense
of hearing but also you can introduce
new senses which is kind of crazy but
here's a question i've been wondering
about it could go with ar or vr um
what do you think is more important for
people to adopt this tech uh the actual
quality of the tech and the experience
itself
or
the the minimalization of the form
factor because i'm thinking you
mentioned earlier like the glasses maybe
having like a thicker rim but not too
thick and and being relatively
unobstructive is that as important or do
you which which do you focus on first
well i think it's a little different
between virtual and augmented reality
for virtual reality because a lot of
people you know you're doing it at home
or you're kind of doing it in an area
where you're
where it's it's kind of reasonable to be
fully immersive
um
you know the way it looks is not
i think the biggest factor right i think
if if we were talking about people
walking down the street wearing a vr
headset i think that would be a
different situation but that kind of
doesn't work you don't want to be fully
immersed right in some other world where
you're walking down the street
that's where augmented reality comes in
so for vr i think there are all these
reasons why you want to get it smaller
right you want to make it more portable
um
of course you want it to be more
comfortable the lighter it is the the
kind of more comfortable it's going to
be for people to use and and of course
anything that people are going to use
you want to be cool right you want it to
look cool right inside when you care
about how the headphones that you're
using look right it's like it's you know
you probably like the design of them
right so it's something that that
matters um
and that's something that we work on
for ar i think there's going to be a
completely new threshold um you know
because that's meant to be worn and and
you're interacting with the world around
you and just bringing holograms into the
world that i think has a very high bar
for kind of aesthetics
and um and feeling like um it's a normal
pair of glasses so you know it's if you
think about the range of glasses on that
from you know really thin rimmed glasses
to pretty thick rimmed glasses i don't
know if we can cram all the electronics
into a very thin rimmed glasses anytime
soon but the goal is going to be to try
to get all the electronics and things
that we need to produce that into kind
of a normal thick rimmed pair of glasses
i think that that matters but then in
the meantime
for virtual reality um you know we just
want to get it as light as possible so
for quest two the goal um you know we we
got it ten percent lighter than quest
one right we shaved off um about 60
grams and we made it so that it's it's
not just lighter it's also smaller right
so it um you know it's um
the the headset piece is smaller but
also the strap is a soft strap instead
of the hard strap
which
when you when it was a little heavier
you kind of needed a hard strap in order
to
make it so the weight distribution
worked on your head and that the harder
strap could kind of support that but now
that it's lighter we cross the threshold
where you can get the soft strap then
that has a double benefit because now
the soft strap makes it a lot smaller so
i can just you know chuck it in my
backpack when i'm on the go a lot more
easily and it makes it a lot more
portable so it's functional so look that
that kind of thing really matters
and we're definitely going to continue
focusing on
just smaller
faster processors better screens until
you get down to the retina displays we
also were able to lower the price from
399 to 299 which i just think is going
to make it possible for a lot more
people to access that and get into vr
and that's something that i'm really
excited about also when i when i
whenever i think about ar i think my
brain naturally goes back to remembering
google glass back in the day
and i'm curious when you're thinking
about the future of what you want ar to
look like do you ever look back at the
past like was was google glass ahead of
its time
well i think that the idea that you're
going to want to have some information
and context there
um
i think it makes sense to work on that
but
and i think that you will see other
types of glasses come out i i'd imagine
you know i don't know what apple and
others are working on but no there's
there's one version that the tech can
take which um
which i think you can kind of put you
can kind of think of as like a smart
watch on your face right so it's like
what do you use your smart watch for you
know notifications um you know maybe
some information and maybe you could
have that in the corner of your eye um
would that be interesting
yeah i think that there some people
might like that that's not personally
the thing that i'm super excited about
building um
for a number of reasons one is i come at
this from the perspective of how do we
connect people better so you know having
some some kind of uh information in the
corner of your eye is a different is is
just not as powerful from my perspective
is being able to have like hologram
marquez here with me um and and being
able to like to to interact and and kind
of share objects or or play a game
physically together um
that i think is just like a completely
different value proposition that's gonna
be harder to build um but i think it's
worth waiting for um to to get to that
so i think you'll kind of see different
things google last was sort of an early
take on the kind of smart watch on the
face type of thing and um i don't know
i'm sure others will try that too that's
um you know that's not the main thing
that we're that we're focused on trying
to build gotcha so i have a have a
little bit of a rapid fire a little yeah
little this or that questions
and uh we'll see what you think okay
algorithmic or chronological ooh well i
mean
i feel like i'm kind of the algorithmic
guy so um yeah so
it's i mean look there's there's a place
for both at the end of the day if your
cousin or someone you know if they have
a baby or some milestone happens it's
like
you just kind of expect that you're
gonna see that and people get upset when
when they miss that because you know it
was 40 posts down because it was in
chronological order so i think the
ranking um is more valuable
um the other thing that we just found is
that when we made the whole thing
chronological it basically encouraged
people to spam right because a lot of
pages were like oh i could get to the
top by by just posting stuff really
really frequently which
so i kind of think like having an option
to see see things chronological in a
world where most pages expect that their
content is going to have to be ranked
and therefore has to be good content um
is a valuable is kind of a good balance
but having it go all chronological i
think kind of produces some bad effects
got it i feel like that's the the
level-headed algorithmic answer i prefer
good algorithmic to
chronological uh favorite non-facebook
app um well i mean these days
i'm in purple air a lot but i don't know
if that's um that's good i mean that's
that's because of the the california
wildfires it's the air
quality app it's i think
um yeah i mentioned spotify earlier i i
probably spend more time in spotify than
almost any other app i
like music a lot same um i think daniel
is a great entrepreneur and a good
person um and it's it's a good company
and i think they've just done a great
job with their work all right phone in
your pocket right now
um you know i've been using samsung
phones for a few years and and i'm i'm a
big fan of them and you know i think i
think that they build great phones um i
i like android um i also just think you
know someone who's building a company
where you know billions of people around
the world use
our products you know most of them use
android phones so i think it's um pretty
good for for me and for the management
team of the company to um have exposure
to using different android phones
instead of all just having iphones which
you know a lot of it would probably be
the default for for a lot of folks uh
last one craft hickory smoked barbecue
or sweet baby race i mean is that even a
question it's uh i mean
i mean i think it's it's well known in
on the internet that i am uh
a sweet baby raised fan
um
i i i
i like barbecuing um
and i guess i guess i'm a sweet baby
raised fanboy fair to say mark thanks
for joining me i appreciate the time i
know you're a busy guy so taking the the
minutes uh to spend with me was
appreciated and hopefully uh i'll take
all this this new knowledge about the
future of vr and ar with me awesome all
right well thanks for having me
appreciate it all right see ya